herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
heute ist ein besonderer Tag mit zwei
bedeutsamen besuchen dem zum einen der
amerikanische Präsident US-Präsident
beiden auf einem überraschungsblitz
Besuch in Kiew und China Chef Diplomat
one je soll in Moskau sein beide Besuche
sind vor einem gewissen Hintergrund zu
sehen am Wochenende bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz da wurden die Ohren
gespitzt als Chinas Chef Diplomat von
einer chinesischen Friedensinitiative
für den Ukraine Krieg sprach
gleichzeitig warnte der Westen mit
knallharten deutlichen Worten davor
Waffen an Russland zu liefern
US-Außenminister blinken äußerte seine
Besorgnis Peking könnte mit
Waffenlieferungen an Moskau in den
Ukraine Krieg eingreifen dann würde eine
rote Linie überschritten so der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell und nicht nur
die USA auch die EU würden dann
Millionen gegen China verhängen so
deutlich Luxemburgs Außenminister
Asselborn das also der Hintergrund und
vor diesem Hintergrund nun heute ein
unangekündigter Blitzbesuch von Joe
Biden beim ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski in Kiew im Gepäck ein neues
Paket an Militärhilfe für die Ukraine im
Volumen von 500 Millionen US-Dollar das
wichtigste aber der Besuch ist ein
deutliches Signal an Moskau und auch an
China denn zeitgleich wurde heute in
Moskau Chinas top Diplomat one je
erwartet der Mann der in München
ankündigte das Chinas Staatschef heating
am Jahrestag des Krieges am 24.02 am
Freitag also eine friedensrede halten
werde dieser Mann nun wurde in Moskau zu
Gesprächen über eine mögliche
Friedensregelung erwartet so hieß es
offiziell
schafft China nun Frieden oder liefert
China am Ende Waffen an Russland wie
sind diese beiden Besucher zeitgleich
heute einzuordnen wir wollen das ganze
besprechen einordnen zum einen mit dem
china-experten Nico ruhotari vom
Mercator Institute for China China
studies und mit unserem USA
Korrespondenten Elma teven und wenn ihr
fragen Kommentare Meinungen habt her
damit dann können wir gemeinsam
diskutieren zunächst aber zu unserem USA
Korrespondenten MRT Wissen der in Polen
ist wo US-Präsident beiden erwartet wird
der morgen dort in Warschau eine
bedeutsame Rede halten wird immer was
bedeutet jetzt erst einmal beides
Blitzbesuch heute in Kiel was hat er
damit selenski besprochen was hat er
versprochen
ja das Wichtigste ist glaube ich ein
klares Signal an Moskau dass die USA
eben unerschütterlich weiter an der
Seite von selensky und von der Ukraine
stehen und das auch die ganzen Gerüchte
und das Gerede darüber dass man in
Amerika gespalten sei dass die
Zustimmung nachlässt das ist nicht wahr
hat Joe Biden Präsident selenski gesagt
dass betrifft vielleicht Teil in der
Bevölkerung die ein bisschen sich
Gedanken machen wie kann es weitergehen
aber in der Politik das haben wir am
Wochenende auch bei der Münchner
Sicherheitspolitik Konferenz erlebt und
sowohl Demokraten als auch Republikaner
ganz klare Aussage man steht weiter zu
keiner die beiden haben besprochen
natürlich wie es weitergehen kann und
der Präsident selenski hat gefordert das
ist eben noch weiter reichende
Waffensysteme geben muss z.B Raketen mit
einer Reichweite über 150 km und z.B
eben auch Kampfjets mit denen die
Ukraine dann in der Lage wäre auch tief
hinter die jetzt bestehenden Linien
dafür zu sorgen dass die russischen Str
Kräfte unter Druck kommen der Präsident
hat das nicht zugesagt in seinen
öffentlichen Auftritten in Kiew heute
aber wir rechnen eigentlich damit dass
er das in den nächsten Tagen doch tun
könnte zumindest eine Lieferung von
Raketen mit einer Reichweite von 150
Kilometern wenn die Amerikaner das tun
dann wäre die Ukraine künftig in der
Lage eben auch die Nachschubwege zum
Beispiel für die russischen Streitkräfte
auf der Krim abzuschneiden und das wäre
ein klares Signal nach Moskau dass man
auch dazu bereit wäre um weiterhin Druck
zu erzeugen damit zu erzeugen damit es
irgendwann zu einem verhandlungsfrieden
kommen kann
der US Außenminister hat blinken gestern
die Sorge geäußert china könnte Waffen
an Moskau liefern hören wir einfach mal
in einen O-Ton von ihm rein ein
Interview mit dem amerikanischen Sender
wir machen uns große Sorgen dass China
darüber nachdenkt Waffen an Russland zu
liefern das hätte ernsthafte
Konsequenzen für unsere Beziehungen
linken sagt er habe sich mit rangier in
München auch darüber unterhalten also
wohl seine Sorgen oder vielleicht diese
rote Linie diese Warnung
ausgedrückt wie berechtigt die real ist
denn diese Angst der Amerikaner das eben
China eingreift das China Waffen an
Russland liefert
das wissen wir eben nicht ganz genau
weil Außenminister blinken keine Belege
dafür vorgelegt hat dass China
tatsächlich immer weg militärische
mittelausrüstungsgegenstände vielleicht
auch Waffen und Munition nach Moskau zu
liefern es würde nicht so recht
übereinstimmen wenn das so wäre mit dem
was am Wochenende auch angekündigt hat
dass er nämlich eine Friedensinitiative
besprechen will in Moskau und das eben
der Präsident Ping Chinas Präsident zum
Jahrestag des Kriegsbeginns also am
kommenden Freitag eine Art Friedensplan
vorlegen will dieser würde natürlich
zerstört werden wenn man tatsächlich
Waffen z.B nach Moskau liefert die USA
sagen sie hätten Hinweise darauf und
wollen ein sehr sehr klares Signal
senden wenn China bereit wäre Moskau
jetzt auch militärisch zu unterstützen
dann würden die USA China als
Unterstützer des Angriffs sehen und dann
eben auch Sanktionen verhängen sie haben
gewisse bewusstseinsaktionspaket fertig
vorliegen dass auf China angewendet
werden könnte und die Worte die wir am
Wochenende von Außenminister blinken
gehört haben dienten wahrscheinlich dazu
abzuschrecken und dafür zu sorgen dass
Wladimir Putin was das angeht weiterhin
alleine da steht also von amerikanischer
Seite eben klare Worte deutliche Worte
Tacheles reden aber das gibt ja auch
kommt ja auch umgekehrt von chinesischer
Seite heute umgekehrt hat der Sprecher
des chinesischen Außenministeriums
zurückgegiftet es sein ja die USA nicht
die Chinesen die dauernd Waffen auf das
Schlachtfeld in der Ukraine schicken
würden werfen würden und er sagte auch
noch dieses
in Bezug auf die Ukraine Frage hat mangi
unterstrichen dass China die ganze Zeit
über eine konstruktive Rolle gespielt
hat und Friedensgespräche fördert die
umfassende strategische Partnerschaft
zwischen China und Russland beruht auf
nicht Bündnis nicht Konfrontation und
nicht Angriffen auf dritte sie ist eine
Angelegenheit innerhalb zweier
souveräner Staaten wie akzeptieren
keinerlei herumkommandieren oder
druckseitens der USA sie sollten eine
politische Lösung der Krise fördern
anstatt Öl ins Feuer zu gießen oder ihre
eigenen Vorteile zu suchen
also ich würde mal sagen giftige Worte
oder salopp gesprochen da pampt man sich
ordentlich an ist das weiß ich nicht der
neue Stil irgendwie zwischen Washington
und Peking dass man sehr sehr sehr offen
sagt was man denkt
nein das ist nicht neu wir hatten im
März 2021 also kurz nach dem Amtsantritt
von Joe Biden schon ein ich sag mal
historisches Treffen von One je aber
auch young Yeshi das sind im Grunde um
die führenden Köpfe in der Außenpolitik
Chinas zu dem Zeitpunkt gewesen mit Toni
blinken und Jake salvin den nationalen
Sicherheitsberater und da hat man
Tacheles geredet man hat sich sehr klar
und eindeutig an den Kopf geworfen was
man voneinander hält das in China die
Menschen und Bürgerrechte mit Füßen
getreten werden das China andere Staaten
erpresst umgekehrt hat China den USA
damals vorgeworfen dass sie im Grunde
genommen die Welt dominieren und alle
erpressen wollen mit ihrer
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen Macht
also man spricht hier gerne klare Worte
und das ist eine Strategie ich glaube
auf beiden Seiten aber besonders auch
auf Seiten der USA man will im Grunde
genommen Klarheit darüber haben was man
voneinander zu halten hat und dann auf
dieser Basis miteinander erkunden ob man
nicht vielleicht in dem ein oder anderen
fällt doch zusammenarbeiten kann und das
schien ja in den letzten Monaten
gelingen in Sachen Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel hat man Vereinbarungen
getroffen Toni blinken hätte wenn er
nach Peking gereist wäre wenn nicht der
spionageballon dazwischen gekommen wäre
hätte er auch da Tacheles geredet aber
hätte eben zusammen mit den Chinesen
erkundet ob man sich wirtschaftlich und
auch politisch wieder ein Stück weit
näher kommt eigentlich haben alle damit
gerechnet dass das passiert aber jetzt
ist der Jahrestag des Kriegsbeginns ganz
offenbar anders eben zumindest verbal
wieder heftige schlagabtäuschte sich zu
liefern immer du hast ja gerade gesagt
dass US-Präsident Joe beiden vor allen
Dingen eines versucht hat deutlich zu
machen in Kiew gegenüber Moskau dass man
eben nicht gespalten sei in den USA
jetzt fragt den Punkt K über Youtube
haben die Republikaner denn aber nicht
gesagt dass kein Cent mehr für die
Ukraine gespendet werden also gibt es
nicht doch eine gewisse Spaltung
zwischen da der Regierung beiden in
Demokraten und den Republikaner
also es gibt definitiv eine Spaltung
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
die Äußerungen die wir gerade gehört
haben stammen von Republikanern im
Abgeordnetenhaus von denen einige
tatsächlich sagen dass man die Ukraine
nicht mehr weiter unterstützen sollte
dass Amerika schon viel zu viel an
Steuergeldern in die Aufrüstung der
Ukraine gesteckt hat das sagen eben jene
Abgeordnete die in ihren Wahlkreisen
auch Druck bekommen aus der Bevölkerung
weil Menschen tatsächlich auch
hinterfragen ob diese Unterstützung so
weitergehen soll und ob irgendwann ein
Ende dieses Krieges in Sicht ist aber
die große Mehrheit der Republikaner im
amerikanischen Kongress allen voran auch
die Senatoren und Abgeordneten die am
Wochenende bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz waren die haben
ganz klar und eindeutig gesagt sie
stehen 100% hinter Ukraine und sind auch
der Meinung dass man weiter noch mehr
Waffen liefern muss um sicherzustellen
dass die Ukraine eine bestmögliche
Ausgangsposition hat um irgendwann doch
einmal den Verhandlungen einzutreten man
will dafür sorgen dass Putin das Gefühl
bekommt auch für ihn ist am Ende ein
verhandlungsfrieden besser dafür muss er
allerdings wenigstens ein paar
Zentimeter von seinem ursprünglichen
Kriegszielen abrücken ja der ist ja
genau immer ist eine Sache ziemlich
spannend letzte Frage kurze Antwort
bitte morgen spricht Putin erhält seine
Rede zur Lage der Nation und
gleichzeitig haben wir schon gesagt
spricht beiden in Polen kein Zufall
dieses Fernduell oder
nein das ist es mit Sicherheit nicht wir
hören aus dem Weißen Haus dass man
bewusst diesen Termin auch gewählt hat
um eben ein gegen narrativ aufzumachen
Joe Biden wird wie letztes Jahr im März
schon hier am Warschauer schloss eine
große Rede halten so wird uns gesagt wo
er noch einmal klar macht das ist die
große Auseinandersetzung zwischen
liberaler Demokratie und Autoritarismus
ist und es geht um mehr als nur den
Konflikt in Europa sondern auch um ein
klares Signal an China dass die
Unabhängigkeit dass die Selbstbestimmung
und die territoriale Integrität eben zu
beachten ist und das gilt eben auch
gegenüber Taiwan und deswegen ist diese
Rede auch morgen mit großer Spannung
erwartet und so wichtiger als
amerikanischer Sicht um die Demokratien
Europas und auch in anderen Teilen der
Welt hinter sich zu versammeln wir
werden darüber berichten und vielen Dank
erstmal jetzt Elmar für deine Einordnung
und Einschätzungen ausholen wo ähm jo
bei den jetzt erwartet wird vielen Dank
Elmar nach
Warschau ja wie gesagt gestern noch
sprach Chinas top außen Diplomat waren
je auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
und gespannt hörte ihm der Saal und die
ganze Welt wohl zu als er auch diese
Satz sagte
Chinas Herangehensweise an das Thema
Ukraine kann man kurz zusammenfassen auf
Frieden zu drängen und Gespräche
voranzutreiben in diesem Sinne werden
wir eine chinesische Position für eine
politische Lösung der ukraine-krise
präsentieren wir stehen weiter fest an
der Seite von Frieden und der Seite des
Dialogs
heute nun ist genau dieser Mann in
Moskau was bedeutet das reden wir mit
dem china-experten
mikrowotari vom Mercator Institut for
China studies darüber schönen guten
Abend guten Abend heute ist dieser
top-diplomat der in Moskau erwartet
worden wie ist das ganze nun
einzuschätzen können wir jetzt hoffen
dass er dort tatsächlich Gespräche
geführt hat um einer Friedensregelung
für die Ukraine näher zu kommen oder
ging es vielleicht dabei um etwas ganz
anderes was ist ihre Einschätzung
erstmal ist es ein starkes Signal auch
das Ski an der Seite Putins steht am
Jahrestag in Moskau aufzutreten spricht
natürlich Bände und die Hoffnung hier
auf einen Friedensplan aus Peking
scheint mir doch sehr verfehlt hat es
recht deutlich gesagt es geht darum die
chinesische Position für eine mögliche
politische Lösung des Konflikts zu
klären also es geht da erstmal darum
dass China die Initiative ergreift um
Vorwürfen auch entgegen zu treten dass
es sozusagen ein Beistand ein ein
Zuschauer an diesen Konfliktes da geht's
auch natürlich darum Vorwürfen aus der
Europäischen Union und aus anderen
Teilen der Welt entgegenzutreten dass
man möglicherweise gar einen unterstütze
oder Profiteur des Krieges im Moment ist
also insofern geht um die Interessen
Chinas und die sind eng verwoben mit
denen in Moskau und mit Putin
Sven odental stellt sie über Youtube
über Facebook gerade die Frage gibt es
denn schon nähere Informationen über die
von China aus sich gestellte
Friedensinitiative wie könnte die genau
aussehen sie sagen also so konkret ist
das noch gar nicht sondern ein ausloten
aber warum werden diese Worte die wir ja
eben von wangi doch gehört haben von der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz warum
genau das gerade jetzt
erstmal wir wissen in etwa was wir zu
erwarten haben nämlich zum einen hat
runny darauf verwiesen dass die Worte
seines Chefs nämlich das Partei und
Staatschefs cheating dazu gelten haben
es geht darum diese Position zu
wiederholen und da haben wir ja schon
einige Evidenz dafür was das mit sich
bringt es geht darum zum Beispiel zu
wiederholen dass China davor warnt
nukleare Drogen oder gerade den Einsatz
von Nuklearwaffen
da zum Einsatz zu bringen oder auch den
Schutz von nuklearen Einrichtungen oder
Gefahr von chemischen Angriffen
beispielsweise
betont das sind alles Dinge zu denen
sich in einer seit Jahren oder
Jahrzehnten zum Teil verpflichtet hat
also insofern keine Neuigkeiten es wird
auch wieder betont werden territoriale
Integrität Souveränität Prinzipien der
Vereinten Nationen natürlich welche die
gerade massiv gebrochen werden durch den
Angriff Russlands in der Ukraine also
insofern wir müssen wir wissen schon
etwas was wir uns da einstellen müssen
warum jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt mein
Gefühl ist China ist durchaus unter
Druck jetzt etwas da aus dem
Hintertreffen zu kommen global hat sich
doch die Meinung die Position auch
vieler Staaten die vielleicht latent an
der Seite der bricks der Brasiliens
Russlands Italiens Chinas standen also
insbesondere in Brasilien gibt es
Bewegung sich auch stärker zu
positionieren und in der Europäischen
Union wird auf allen Seiten klar gemacht
dass wenn China sich nicht bewegt in
diesem Konflikt eben zunehmen Peking
auch im Fahrwasser Russland gesehen wird
und das ist etwas was natürlich
mittelfristig nicht im Interesse Peking
ist
jetzt kommt die spannende Frage von
Niklas Kopf angenommen die angekündigten
Friedensbemühungen Chinas würden wie
gehofft eingeleitet also Peking würde
das ernst meine wäre dies denn dann auch
ein Zeichen was sozusagen anders gibt
auf Entspannung oder die Eskalation in
Bezug auf Taiwan zu hoffen
dass ich nicht noch mal die Führung
Pekings in Peking verfolgt sehr klare
eigene Interessen damit da geht es hier
durchaus darum sein gegenüber den USA
klare Kante zu zeigen gegenüber anderen
Partnern oder vermeintlichen Partnern zu
versuchen zu signalisieren dass man
einen verlässlicher oder ein möglicher
Partner sein kann Rückschlüsse auf
Chinas Friedenswille mit Blick auf
taimern würde ich daraus nicht ziehen da
geht es um eine deutlich größere und
schwieriger Dynamik die mit seiner
eigenen Logik befrachtet ist und da
geht's auch eben um den Einsatz von
Gewalt der als letzte andere auch im
Raum steht
versuchen wir nochmal mit Ihnen diese
Beziehung diese Position China Moskau zu
analysieren man könnte ja sagen ja China
redet jetzt von Frieden schickt wann je
nach Moskau um auf Frieden auf
Möglichkeiten zu drängen weil vielleicht
die Ding der Geduldsfaden reist weil
vielleicht China sagt so langsam muss
jetzt auch mal Ruhe im Karton sein und
das ganze dieser Krieg zu einem Ende
kommen
andererseits sehen wir das ähm ja
Russland isoliert ist aber China immer
noch der Unterstützer ist Russland wäre
ja ganz schlecht dran wenn China
wenigstens wirtschaftlich nicht Russland
unterstützen würde und dann ist er ja
auch noch diese Männer Freundschaft
zwischen hier und Putin insofern wie
sehen Sie das Ganze
es ist eine zentrale Beziehung für beide
Staaten tatsächlich die Dimension der
beiden Führer dort spielt eine wichtige
Rolle das ist ein sicherlich eine tiefe
Beziehung die geprägt ist von einem
gemeinsamen Weltbild von Paranoia von
einer Ablehnung der USA insbesondere
aber die chinesische russische
Beziehungen sind natürlich auch einfach
die von sehr sehr gewichtigen
Nachbarstaaten den es erst in den
letzten 20 Jahren gelungen ist auch von
Grenzstreitigkeiten beispielsweise
abzusehen da hat sich die Beziehung
vertieft in der gemeinsamen Ablehnung
gegenüber dem Westen auch in dem Versuch
alternative Ordnung voranzutreiben und
durch eine durchaus insbesondere für
Russland wichtige sehr wichtige
ökonomische Beziehung im Energiebereich
aber eben auch durch militärische
Lieferung
wie sehen denn diese Lieferungen an
China aus will noch mal darauf kommen
was US-Außenminister blinken gesagt hat
er hatte also einen größte Sorge dass
China Waffen liefern könnte
wirtschaftlich steht China Russland zur
Seite aber wie sieht es denn aus was
wird denn geliefert was wissen Sie wenn
es hier und da heißt ja Mikrochips
werden vielleicht oder Mikroelektronik
wird geliefert die kann man in den Handy
einbauen die kann man die Mikrowelle
einbauen aber die dient ja vielleicht
auch in einem Panzer zu bauen was wissen
sie Überlieferungen ja erstmal muss man
feststellen dass vieles davon sich im
Raum des spekulativen befindet und das
sicherlich eher die Geheimdienste sind
die dort mehrere Kenntnisse haben es ist
bekannt dass China durchaus militärische
Güter liefert die sind nicht letal und
eher sozusagen im Bereich der Ausrüstung
zu finden das findet sich selbst im
statistischen Daten wieder das Ausmaß
davon ist jetzt nicht unglaublich
ausgeprägt da geht's wahrscheinlich pro
Monat um entweder etwa eine Millionen
US-Dollar von Gütern die geliefert
werden das ist nachgewiesen es gibt auch
Hinweise auf ähm
umgehungshandel über Armenien über
Aserbaidschan über andere Staaten
drohnenteile Ausrüstung
Navigationssysteme und ähnliches all das
ist relativ gut belegt aber das genauer
Ausmaß davon und natürlich auch die
Frage wie viel kommt als nächstes
darüber gibt es unsererseits wenig
gesicherte Erkenntnis
aber es scheint wirklich viele User hier
zu bewegen ich schreibe über Youtube was
hätte denn China davon wenn es Russland
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine mit Waffen
und Geld unterstützt
erstmal ist Peking nicht unbedingt als
Profiteur dieser großen und ja zunehmend
gefährlichen Krise zu sehen China
grundsätzlich an Interesse dass dieser
Krieg nicht eskaliert es gibt eine
gewisse was zynische Logik natürlich
dass die USA gebunden sind jetzt auch
durch diesen Konflikt in Europa aber ich
würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen
dass China direkt am Profiteur von
dieser Auseinandersetzung
ist also insofern Waffenlieferung oder
die Lieferung von militärischen
ausrüstungsgütern dient aus der
Perspektive Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
schlicht und einfach dazu
weiterhin Geschäfte zu machen aber
natürlich auch sozusagen nicht im Regen
stehen zu lassen china möchte das
Russland in diesen Krieg ähm nicht zum
verlieren wird dieses Interesse ist klar
geäußert aus der Perspektive Pekings ist
der
Hauptschuldige oder die Ursache dieses
Krieges in der nato-expension und dem
Verhalten der USA zu sehen also insofern
Kinder steht das Fest an Moskau Seite
stärkt den Rücken ohne aber eben das ist
der Versuchung im Westen den Rücken zu
wenden
das fast Andreas Böhme hier in anderen
Worten zusammen ist genau der Gedanke er
schreibt über Youtube China interessiert
nur das Geschäft und man kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass man sich das Geschäft
mit dem Westen oder dass man das
Geschäft mit dem Westen riskiert also
wie sie es eben sagen als Bild Moskau
den Rücken stärken aber dem Westen nicht
den Rücken zu wenden also die Geschäfte
weiter machen eine rein ja theoretische
Frage noch mal hier von ich über Youtube
was für schwere Waffen würde denn die
Volksrepublik China im Falle einer
russischen Unterstützung senden was
könnte denn China senden wahrscheinlich
ist das Repertoire und das ja Angebot
groß
ja aber noch mal wir müssen erstmal
festhalten das halten wir stand jetzt
nicht für das wahrscheinlichste Ort
kommt die Indizien die geliefert worden
sind bislang deuten eher auf Gespräche
in die sowas theoretisch in den Raum
stellen
sicherlich benötigt würden von Russland
allerlei Ersatzteile für Flugzeuge für
Panzer
Drohnen wären sicherlich hoch auf der
Liste dafür gibt's Hinweise dass der
Teile zumindest geliefert worden sind
also insofern ich Shoppingliste wäre
sicherlich groß aber noch mal ich finde
es sehr wichtig dass wir hier nüchtern
bleiben und drauf schauen stand jetzt
ist es im Wesentlichen nicht literales
militärisches ausrüstungszeug was
geliefert worden ist und er erzählt hat
ja auch gesagt bisher sind keinerlei
Beweise
vorgelegt worden man muss natürlich auch
die Worte von dem US Außenminister genau
sehen der eben sagt dass man
Informationen hat dass man eventuell
eine Bereitstellung tödlicher
Unterstützung erwogen werden würde
da haben sie völlig recht müsste man
also vorsichtig sein trotzdem ist es ja
sehr interessant was nun gestern was
heute passiert ist rote Linien sind klar
gezogen worden MRT wir sind hat ja auch
analysiert und gesagt das ist die
Politik von beiden auch von China dass
man eben sich klipp und klar sagte woran
man ist was vielleicht hilfreich ist nun
ist klipp und klar gesagt worden sollte
China Waffen liefern sollte diese rote
Linie überschritten werden dann äh das
haben die USA klar gedroht würden es
Sanktionen der schärfsten Form geben
immer hat uns ja auch erklärt ein Paket
wurde bereit liegen und die EU das haben
wir auch eben gehört Borell hat es
gesagt andere eben auch dann würde die
EU ebenfalls Sanktionen verhängen jetzt
schauen wir mal ganz kurz da drauf
welche Folgen das denn hätte wie sieht
denn die Handelsbilanz der Handel mit
China aus da sehen wir die USA
importieren im Wert von 537 Milliarden
Dollar aus China dem gegenüber stehen
Exporte nach China in Höhe von 154
Milliarden Dollar unterm Strich also ein
Handelsbilanzdefizit in Höhe von 383
Milliarden Dollar ähnlich der Handel der
EU mit China die Exporte mit 562
Milliarden Dollar gut doppelt so hoch
wie die Importe sprich ein
Handelsdefizit der EU mit China von 277
Milliarden Dollar jetzt Nummer
angenommen Herr rotary es käme zu einem
Konflikt des käme also zu Sanktionen wen
würde das denn dann am meisten treffen
oder beide gleich
erstmal müssen wir feststellen dass das
ein Super-GAU gleich kämen das wie die
Worte jetzt nicht zu drastisch wählen
aber eine Kernschmelze der globalen
Wirtschaft wäre Implikationen davon
hier würden alle so schwer getroffen
dass das abwägen wie es vielleicht
stärker trifft aus meiner Perspektive in
sekundärer Gedanke ist mit so einem
sanktions-szenario würden wir uns in
einer Abwärtsspirale Bewegen von der
alle betroffen werden und im übrigen
natürlich die Frage in welcher Form
durch die EU wirklich ganz konkret
anschließen würde ist für mich nicht
ganz ausgemacht sondern ich glaube nicht
dass wir hier vollständige Einigkeit in
der Europäischen Union derzeit haben
aber es ist natürlich wichtig dass ich
alle Seiten auch möglichst rational
darauf vorbereiten welche Risiken von so
einem Szenario ausgehen ich hoffe sehr
dass der chinesischen Seite das auch
bewusst ist weil in der Tat natürlich
wäre auch China dramatischen schwer
davon betroffen ich glaube es geht nicht
darum jetzt sozusagen in dem ersten
sanktionsschritt dann gleich größere
Kaliber dort aufzufahren sondern würde
wahrscheinlich versuchen da Schritt für
Schritt in so ein Szenario reinzutreten
aber ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass
so etwas kalkulierbar und dann auch noch
kontrollierbar ist
aber es sind eben genau die Sorgen die
hier auch User haben Uher Audio schreibt
über Youtube wie könnten denn Sanktionen
gegen China im Ernstfall Aussehen wir
sind doch total abhängig von China und
umgekehrt brauchen die Chinesen eben
auch den Handel mit uns das heißt wie
sie eben sagen eigentlich eine Sache die
von beiden Seiten unvorstellbar wäre
also man würde versuchen wahrscheinlich
erst mal gezielter vorzugehen da gibt es
Listen von Gütern bei denen China
besonders verletzlich wäre da würde man
versuchen den Druck zu erhöhen das gäbe
sozusagen eine sanktionslogik die
versucht bestimmte Akteure zu treffen so
kennt man das ja also nicht so wie man
das auch muss aber wir wissen natürlich
auch wie schwer es ist auch mit den
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland Wirkung
oder gar unmittelbare Wirkung zu
erzielen also insofern noch mal dass es
in höchster verkehrsszenario ähm vor dem
sich alle hoffentlich scheuen werden das
tatsächlich das zu Realitäten und vor
allen Dingen haben wir ja jetzt schon
mit Russland das Beispiel ja deutlich
gesehen dass das ganze irgendwie fast
aus dem Ruder läuft weil auf einmal
Menschen im Sudan hungern und man das ja
gar nicht mehr sozusagen kontrollieren
kann wie Preise sich entwickeln weltweit
also das ganze einzufangen Sanktionen
würde ja auch für alle bitte Beteiligten
äußerlich schwierig richtig
absolut in der Tat und ähm wir sind
jetzt beim zehnten sanktions Paket
gegenüber Russland die Vorstellung dass
wir in so einer Spirale mit China
reinkommt noch mal das ist etwas wo wir
alle viel daran setzen sollten dass das
nicht dazu kommt die Verantwortung liegt
natürlich primär jetzt dazu
ja es gibt auch Kommentare
UTS schreibt über Youtube redet endlich
miteinander anstatt immer mehr Waffen zu
liefern dazu sofort der Kommentar von
Jürgen Töpper über Youtube mit wem denn
reden Papier ist auch geduldig und
Gunnar Geck schreibt über Facebook es
ist schon ein Unterschied ob man einen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
unterstützt oder die Verteidigung gegen
einen solchen das sind ja auch Meinungen
Kommentare die eben auch wichtig sind
allerletzte Frage die USA versuchen sich
weniger abhängig zu machen ich
formuliere es vorsichtig weniger
abhängig zu machen von China indem sie
sagen wir investieren mehr zu Hause
benutzen mehr Rohstoffe von zu Hause so
der vorsichtig geplant von beiden
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg wird
eigentlich nicht müde immer wieder zu
wiederholen zu sagen nach der Erfahrung
was eine Energie Abhängigkeit von
Russland letzten Endes für den Westen
bedeutet sollte man doch daraus gelernt
haben und versuchen die Abhängigkeit von
China zu reduzieren aber die deutsche
Abhängigkeit von China hat in der
letzten Zeit in den letzten Monaten
sogar noch zugenommen wie sehen Sie das
denn als China Experte hat Deutschland
da nicht gelernt ist es völlig unmöglich
ähnliches zu tun sich unabhängiger zu
machen
ich glaube es wurde gelernt sowohl in
der Wirtschaft als auch in der Politik
können die Hausaufgaben sind groß und
der Versuch ist da auf allen Seiten
etwas stärkere Resilienz in die
Beziehung mit China reinzubekommen dass
die risking und die Diversifizierung
sind da die Schlagworte da geht es nicht
um eine vollständige entlechtung von
China aber in die Verflochtenheit eben
mehr Sicherheit reinzukommen das ist
eine Riesenaufgabe ist auch für viele
Unternehmen überhaupt noch nicht durch
dekliniert im Einzelnen was das genau
bedeutet wir haben kritische
Abhängigkeit mit Blick auf
rohstoffzulieferung aus China sind in
vielerlei Hinsicht auch sehr stark
verflochten und durchaus strategisch mit
Blick auf einige Zukunftstechnologien
also hier gibt es ein ein
Hausaufgabenheft was groß ist ich glaube
Unternehmen und die Politik wagen sich
da langsam daran ob das zeitnah und
rechtzeitig vor dann diesen tiefen
diopolitischen Brüchen vor denen wir
stehen noch geschehen kann das ist eine
glaube ich wichtige Frage aber der
Versuch scheint mir mittlerweile
also viele Hausaufgaben noch viele Dinge
auf die wir gemeinsam auch noch schauen
werden am 24 am Jahrestag am Freitag
erwarten wir eben die ja friedensrede
von cheating pink und wir werden sie
gespannt verfolgen und schauen ob sie
dann eben recht haben und das ganze dann
auch demnächst auch die wirtschaftlichen
weiteren Entwicklung mit ihnen einordnen
Hero Tarif vielen vielen Dank für die
Expertise für die Analyse vielen Dank
dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben
vielen Dank
ja das war unser ZDF heute live zur
Rolle Chinas im Ukraine Krieg und auch
zum Besuch des US-Präsidenten in Kiew
ich sage vielen Dank für das Interesse
für ihre Meinungen Fragen und Kommentare
tschüss einen schönen Abend noch bis
bald